30 secondstory.
>> What's your point?
>> The future looks bright.
>> My handshake is better than anything I
ever sign. It's right here.
>> You are one of my son's.
So, my guest today is Yan Chia Chuin,
and I did my best to pronounce the last
name. I've been looking forward to uh
the conversation with you for quite some
time. The day the interview came out
with you and um I believe it was Osager
and Crystal, which I thought it was
fascinating how a man uh in July of 2024
can predict that Trump's going to win,
then he's going to go to war against
Iran, and then Iran's going to win,
which was your prediction. and I said, I
want to talk to him and then so let's
get the nasty stuff out of the way cuz I
actually want to have a civil
conversation with you. I'm actually very
curious about why you think the way you
think. Uh one uh at the beginning when
we had that uh our team reached out to
you uh to get on the podcast and I think
on a podcast you said you thought it was
going to be a hit piece interview. What
gave you the impression I was going to
do a hit piece on you? Well, it was just
a timing because the day you got in
touch,
um there was a coordinate smear campaign
against me on Twitter, meaning that
there were some influencers who were
using the same talking points against me
um just saying that I just make stuff um
up and uh it seemed very similar. So, I
was very afraid. Also, at that time, I
was I was under a lot of stress. So, I
didn't want to put myself in a situation
where um I would be asked hard questions
and I didn't think I would be able to
respond properly to um to hard questions
and I I watched your show. I'm a huge
fan of yours, Patrick. So, I I I know I
know you're very good. You ask very good
questions.
>> I I appreciate that and and that's a
fair assessment. And then again, the
other part I want to get out of the way
on Medi Assam when you were on there and
professor not professor, we've all seen
that viral stuff that's been out. So if
you're comfortable, I'm going to call
you Jang if that's okay with you as
we're going through it.
>> That's perfect. That's perfect.
Beautiful.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> So, so, so I appreciate that. Uh,
question for you. So, when you said
again, I've seen the entire interview
and I've seen a lot of your stuff
because what I like is seeing what the
market is saying and why, right? Some
people have certain patterns and your
experience is a very interesting one
because you went to Yale College. You've
lived in Canada. You're now in uh uh
Hong Kong if I'm not mistaken.
>> No, no, no, no. Beijing. I'm
>> sorry. My apologies. You're in Beijing
right now. And so you have a very
interesting perspective of these three
different worlds and there's a lot of
things to talk about. what what uh what
analysis or what patterns did you notice
for you to say, you know, not the first
one that Trump was going to win because
let's set that one aside, but the one
that US is going to go to war with Iran
and then we're going to lose. What gave
you the analysis or something to say, I
think that's what's going to happen,
>> right? So um in school I teach history
and I try to teach world history in the
entirety of human history stretching
from the cave paintings u and the United
States about 10,000 years ago to today
and while teaching history I've noticed
some patterns emerge
um in history and the major pattern is
how empires tend to decline and they
decline for a particular reason which is
hubris. So empires believe that they are
invincible um and that no one can touch
them. So they engage in activities that
are not very strategic
um for example the Persians invaded the
Greek mainland in about 490 BC with a
massive invasion force and they were
destroyed by the uh Greeks and then the
Athenian Empire which emerged after the
Persian Empire um started to engage in
hubris as well and in 415 B.CE CE during
the Pelipian war against Sparta, they
launched an ill-advised Silly invasion
of Sicily. Um, and they lost the war
because of this uh in invasion. And so a
pattern emerges where empires in
decline. They tend to engage in risky um
wars that they believe they can win
easily, but which but which forces them
to expand valuable resources on a
quagmire. So most recent example of
course was Vietnam. So it is my belief
that um if the United States would go to
war with Iran then it would lose this
war because United States would not have
the manufacturing capacity the largest
network in order to sustain a war in the
mountainous terrain of Iran. And so the
big question was would Iran go to war?
Uh sorry would the United States go to
war with Iran? If you look at Trump's
first presidency, um there were clear
signs that he was um being heavily
influenced by Israel. Uh he moved the uh
American embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem. He promoted the Abraham
Accords.
>> Um he recognized Israel's control over
the Golan Heights. Uh he ordered the
assassination of General Kasim Salammani
in January 2020. Um, and so if he had a
second term, he would have most
certainly gone to war against Iran. So
that's how I came to my conclusion.
>> Got it. That's fair. And by the way,
there's a very book good book written by
Jim Collins where he says, uh, uh, why
the mighty fall? Why the mighty fall?
And he goes through five steps, stages
of the gland. And it validates what
you're saying. Number one is hubris born
of success. We're great because we're
great and we're untouchable, right?
Number two, an undisiplined pursuit of
more. We all fall fall for this trap
when we succeed. Uh let's go do more,
faster, bigger. Right? Number three is
denial of risk and peril, which is we're
fine. We have nothing to worry about.
Number four is grasping for salvation.
This is what we need a saver. We need
help. And then number four is
capitulations to irrelevance or
irrelevance or death, which is over. I'm
a Syrian. Trust me, we lost our empire
many, many years ago. And we were very,
very powerful. We don't have a country
right now. So, you have to always stay a
little bit paranoid about what could
happen. Now, let me go to the tweet of
what President Trump uh posted on Truth
Social this morning. The world is
reacting to it. A lot of people are not
happy. A lot of people are curious. Some
people are saying this is good. Uh uh
but I would say a lot of the people are
probably on this is crazy what's about
to happen today. JD Vance said something
this morning that it's probably coming
to an end. A whole civilization,
President Trump said, untruth social. A
whole civilization will die tonight.
Never be brought back again. I don't
want that to happen, but it probably
will. However, now that we have complete
and total regime change where different,
smarter, and less radicalized minds
prevail. Maybe something revolutionary
wonderful can happen. Who knows? We will
find out tonight.
One of the most important moments in the
long and complex history of the world.
47 years of extortion, corruption, and
death will finally end. God bless the
great people of Iran. How do you
interpret that tweet?
Um I think that Trump is trying to go
for maximum leverage in negotiation. Uh
but the reality is that the Iranians um
will not back down and American forces
already assembled in the Middle East.
So, I think that we will see a ground
invasion as early as this weekend and
it'll be a multi-vector ground invasion,
meaning that right now the Americans are
attacking Car Island, which is where uh
Iran will export 90% of its oil from and
so the Americans intend on seizing Car
Island and strangling the Iranian
economy. There will probably be an
attack on Kasam Island as well in order
to wrestle control of the Humu of
Hummus. There will also be an attack on
the Iranian coastline in order to um
scout out air defenses. So I think that
we are approaching a major escalation
over next few days.
>> So So try to decode this because the
average person who reads this they say
who talks like that you know what do you
mean a whole civilization will die
tonight never back brought back again.
But if you're somebody that's you seem
like a pattern recognition type of guy
and you kind of watch how people speak
and we know this is how he speaks,
right? He's not the most predictable
guy. He's got predictable side but also
unpredictable side. Decode what he's
saying here. Is is this his last chance
of negotiation for there not to happen?
Is this his last chance of saying I hope
somebody says hey let's go out there and
negotiate with them because Pakistan
tried to bring the peace deal on both
sides and US declined it and so did
Iran. So if you were to decode this a
little bit more on where president's
minds at what would you say?
>> Well I would say that Trump um has a
history of working in reality TV. He
thinks in terms of of television. He
asked himself what will draw attention,
what will look good on TV? What will uh
get people very emotional and afraid and
anxious? So, he spent a lot of time in
the World Wrestling um uh entertainment
with Vince Vince McMahon that they had a
feud, a television feud, and that's
really how you speak in the WWE. You are
rhetorical, you are bomb bombastic, and
you try to instill fear and rage in uh
people. Um
um and so what Trump is trying to do is
he's trying to huff and puff. It's
really flexing. The other issue that's
very worrying right now is that Trump
has surrounded himself with advisors who
are psychopaths and they're not actually
relaying laying to relaying to him uh
good strategic advice. Uh so for example
um what just happened this weekend was
that Trump announced the rescue of a
down American pilot and if you watch the
press conference yesterday um he thought
it was tremendous success and was very
proud of the military for doing the
impossible going deep into enemy lines
and rescuing a wounded uh pilot. Um, and
this is a great tribute to the
professionalism and self-sacrifice of
the American military, especially the
special forces. But on Twitter, on axe,
on social media, what people are saying
is that um, this was actually not
necessarily a successful pilot rescue
operation. It seems that evidence is
emerging that this was a failed seizure,
a failed attempt to seize uh Iran's
uranium, enriched uranium in the Asafan
uh power plant. And if that is the case,
then that was an extremely risky um
mission. And um it and it's very
consequential because America lost about
$300 million worth of planes and
equipment in this failed raid. So my
concern is that Trump has surrounded
himself with advisors who feed his ego.
And Trump himself believes that just by
flexing, just by taking a very tough
negotiating uh position, he can bully
the Iranians into a compromise. Um, so I
think that um, we are in a very
precarious situation right now.
>> What What do you think though? Worst
case that could happen, the best case.
Walk me through what? And by the way,
just out of curiosity, would you
consider yourself a like if we're in
July of 2024, would you say you were a
supporter of Trump? Like you wanted to
see him win?
Um, so,
um, I'm I'm pretty politically neutral,
but in July 2024, I was very confident
Trump would win and I felt that America
needed a change. So, if I were American
and I had the opportunity to vote in
November of 2024, I would have voted for
Trump over Biden.
>> Got it. That's very important. That's
very important for the audience to know
that because I don't think you've you've
revealed that cuz your your criticism is
just what you think's going to happen.
But you still would have chosen a Trump
over a Biden or a Kamala. Now here's the
question that we're we're you know
everywhere we're we're talking to
others. What's the best case worst case?
Okay, on what could happen here? The
best case scenario is that the Americans
and Iranians reach a compromise where
they agree to share the share of humus.
So they'll be toast collected uh because
the Iranians want reparations for all
the damage that uh the Israelis and
Americans caused these uh this past
month. uh but they agree to share with
the Americans and they agree to collect
the tolls in US dollars and all
sanctions are are lifted and peace comes
to the Middle East and there is a
possibility I'm not saying this is
impossible uh but but it is a very low
probability and this would be the best
case scenario
>> best case scenario give me the worst
>> the worst case scenario is that Trump
follows through and uh bombs all of
Iran's power plants. And the reason why
this is the worst case scenario is that
there are certain individuals
who are now um trying to protect the um
power plants with their bodies. So the
Iranian government has called on for the
young people
>> of Iran to make the ultimate sacrifice
and make a human chain around all power
plants in Iran. And so the Americans go
in, they blow up all the power plants
and kill a lot of young people. Well, in
this case, the Iranians are obligated
now to destroy the entire economy of the
GCC. This would include all oil fields.
This would include all the dalination
plants. Um, this would include all data
centers. And this would be the absolute
worst case scenario.
>> What's your likelihood of that
happening? Give a percentage. Like if
you're going to do a cow sheet type of I
think that's a 1% 2%. If you were a
betting man, what would you say it is?
>> So, I would say best case scenario is
1%. I would say worst case scenario is
10%. And I would say a limited ground uh
incursion would be about 40%.
>> Okay. So you have a higher likelihood of
us hitting the power plants than the
best case scenario happening. 10 times
more likely the worst case than the best
case. How does Trump because your your
prediction was Trump wins, Trump goes to
war with Iran and America loses. Define
losing because some people could say
Afghanistan was a loss, right? the way
Biden left, you know, we left whatever
$83 billion of costs. We left $7 billion
of equipment there, whatever the numbers
are. Uh define loss. What does loss mean
to you?
>> Right. So loss means that America is
forced to retreat from the Middle East
and this will enable Iran to um control
the GCC countries because remember the
GCC is very important for the petro
dollar system where the GCC sells its
oil in US dollars and then recycles this
back into American economy primarily by
investing in uh AI. So a lot of these AI
data data centers are financed by
investment from these GCC self-s
sovereign wealth funds. And if and so if
America were to retreat from the Middle
East, uh they would lose the petro
dollar, the American economy would
collapse. Uh and you would you would
have um a civil war emerge in America.
>> A civil war emerge in America. Okay. Uh
interesting. Do do you think do you
think uh uh the president
has a team of rivals right now that are
trying to prevent that from happening?
Because I think that you and I both know
the the the president is a what do you
think asking everybody what are your
thoughts? What do you think? What do you
think? Including his enemies. I mean
this guy called Elizabeth Warren and
said hey what do you think about us
doing this to the credit card companies?
And Elizabeth Warren's like he just c I
was confused when he called me. you
know, President Trump will bring Mandani
in and say, "Hey, don't worry about it.
Be critical. Say whatever you want to
say about me. I'm okay with that. You
don't need to explain yourself." So, he
talks to everybody. Do Do you think he
is fully uh um aware of the risks of
what could happen if he goes aggressive
here? Do you think he's fully aware
aware of it? I think unfortunately he's
starting himself with psychops, right?
So, uh President Trump said about a
couple weeks ago um when people asked
him why are we in this war? because he
has never really articulate a reason or
an objective for this war. And he
basically said that well Jared Kushner,
Steve Wov, Peter Hsev, Marco Rubio
talked me into it. So what he's done is
he's basically elevated the um hawkish
elements of his administration and
basically
um ostracized or put on the sidelines
the more um um cautionary conservative
elements of his uh administration who
include JD Vans and Taly Gabard. So I
think I believe that JD Vance has been
uh very vocal in trying to negotiate a
peace treaty as soon as possible and now
he's in Hungary far away from the action
and there's rumors of Tulsi Gabbard
being removed from the administration at
some point.
>> Yeah, Tulsi I think there was another
name as well. Tulsi and Howard Lutnik
were the two names that were brought up
yesterday that may be next on the
>> you know chopping blocks that he may
move on from. Going back to it, Iran,
IRGC,
your opinion on them, you hear the
phrase, you know, they're the biggest uh
uh producers of terrorism or there's
many different phrases people use
against them. How dangerous do you think
Iran is led by the current regime to the
world, especially to the Gulf States,
the six GCC countries you're talking
about? But how dangerous you think they
are to society if this regime stays in
power?
So I think there are many factions
within Iran that are very concerned that
if this war continues, the re
revolutionary um uh guards will be able
to control all of Iranian society. Um so
right now they can control about 50% of
the economy, but if this war continues,
they might control 100% of the Iranian
economy. And this would be disastrous
for the uh for other um factions within
Iran who want a progressive secular
society. And remember that this um these
people have a have a grudge against
America. So in 1979
uh students in Tran uh overran the
American uh embassy and took people
hostage. People don't know this but the
those students are now running the re
refugee guar corp. Also their leader uh
Kasam Salammani was killed by the
Americans in January 2020 and they they
wanted revenge against Americans for the
longest time and now it's a perfect
opportunity. So there's a there's a lot
of blood um bad blood between the
Americans and the uh revenue guarant
corp see this as an opportunity to
destroy the Americans once and for for
all even at the cost of their own
society. So there's a real threat here.
>> That's interesting. So if you know have
you ever watched the Godfather the the
Godfather series? I'm assuming you have.
>> I have. Okay. So if if you know this and
you know that
>> if Iran hated us a year ago, if Iran
hated us 8 years ago when we killed
Gasamsmani,
how much more do they hate us today
after taking out the 50 plus leaders
that we have in the last, you know, four
or five weeks, whatever the how many
days are we at? 43, 44 days, I don't
know the exact days. How much more do
they hate us? So, don't you think from a
purely a power play standpoint, if you
went this far and you killed everyone
and you back off, whether you support
this happening or not, we're already in
it. Of course, we could have had the
debate 45 days ago, don't do it. But now
we're in it. If you're this far and you
get out, didn't you just make Iran even
angrier to want to retaliate to US and
the rest of the world?
Yeah, I mean I I think it's very hard to
see a offramp here because the Iranians
will not give up. Even if Americans were
to leave, uh the Iranians would assert
control over the GCC, right? And that's
why Saudi Arabia and uh the uh UAE are
pressuring Trump to finish this war,
right? So what so it's easy to start a
war start the war?
>> What do you think is the right move?
What what do you're an adviser? you
you've said a lot of crazy things which
is which is very interesting and I I
like to hear what you're saying because
we you know when everybody is saying the
same exact thing you're not learning
leaks you need to hear and what other
people are saying what do you think is
the right move to do here right now for
both US and the Gulf States
>> if I were the Gulf States and uh and I
if I were the United States my advice
would be to organize a conference for
four countries the United States Russia
Iran and and China do not include the
Europeans, do not include uh the GCC, do
not include Israel. The just these four
countries, United States, uh Russia,
China and Iran and come to a collective
agreement where these four nations agree
on a new trade relationship based on the
US dollar. I think all four nations are
interested in maintaining the dollar as
a global reserve currency because no one
else wants that global reserve currency
status. Um,
>> why would why why would you why would
you do that if the if those three all
hate you and if you're in a meeting with
them, China's not necessarily an ally.
Russia's not necessarily an ally. Iran's
not necessarily an ally. Why would I
hold this meeting knowing it's three
against one? Trump would never host a
meeting like that knowing the leverage
isn't on him, right? And so he he's got
the support of Gulf States. They're on
his side. He knows he doesn't with
China. He knows he doesn't with Russia.
He knows he definitely doesn't with
Iran. Why host a meeting like that? I I
don't see the logic behind that. Feel
free to push back. I don't see the logic
behind that.
>> Well, I mean, the reality is that um
America is going to have a hard time
holding on to its empire. And Tro has
said this many times. uh because America
is the world reserve currency because
America is responsible for protecting
the sea lanes then America is basically
screwed by the world especially the
Europeans who don't have to pay for
their own own defense um and who can use
their savings to fund their lavish
welfare and pension system. Right? So
it's not in the best interest of America
to maintain its empire. If you're an
average American, you're paying way too
much um for this empire. So, why not
just retreat back into the Western
Hemisphere? The Western Western
Hemisphere is completely
self-sufficient. It has Canada, Mexico.
Hey, if I'm Trump, I'm like, you know
what? Screw Iran. Screw Ukraine. I don't
need these places. I'm going to take
over Canada and Mexico because Mexico
has a surplus of labor, cheap labor, and
Canada has infinite resources.
>> A lot of people agree with you on that.
A lot of people agree with you. But, but
here's the problem though, Junk. The
problem is we're in in too deep right
now. So this is a good conversation 45
days ago. I'm saying to you, we just
killed the top 50 leaders. These are
they're not going they're they're a
martyr type community. Like you know how
you ever go against the company and
they're very ligious and you want to
play nice and they're like no we're
latigious. Sue sue sue sue sue. You have
to fight fight. You know firewood fire.
So, I'm talking today. If you go in the
room and say, "Okay, let's play nice
with Iran." They're like, "You're out of
your flipping mind." And if we say,
"Hey, Iran says we want to play nice."
You're you're out of and we know Russia
and China are going to side with them. I
I don't I don't know if that strategy
works today. I do know. Do you think Do
you think Trump has a ton of leverage
over NATO right now? Do you think the
leverage he has over NATO?
>> Look, you can make the argument that
Trump is not just at war with Iran.
Trump is ultimately at war with the
globalists, right? the city of London,
Wall Street, global finest. Yes. Right.
So NATO represents a globalist and Trump
hates NATO and NATO hates Trump.
>> Um I think Trump has been trying very
hard to come to an agreement with Putin
for the longest time. They had that
anguish Alaska meeting. And what
happened afterwards? Well, NATO um and
Ukraine are continued to um attack uh
Russia. There there was that drone
assassination attempt against Putin. Um
the Ukrainians have blown up 40% of uh
Russia's oil exports just most recently.
So there's a lot of bad blood between um
Ukraine and Russia between the
globalists and and and and Trump. So if
you're Trump, right, who's your enemy?
Is your enemy Iran, Russia, and China,
or is your enemy NATO and the
globalists?
Well,
he he's he's constantly complimentary of
his relationship with Xi and Putin. If
you ever notice when he speaks is look,
you know, I'd rather be friendly than
not friendly. We had a good talk. We're
going to go visit back in May. We have
some scheduling conflict. We're going to
go back. I had a good talk with Putin.
Had a good talk with G. So, he he knows
how to speak to these power players and
have them under control. It looks like,
you know, that night when he was given a
speech, the 23minut speech, which 9:00
p.m. I I think this was last week. I
thought he was going to say something
radical like we're leaving NATO. I
thought he was going to say the Gulf has
announced they're funding the war. I
thought he was going to make some kind
of a big announcement like that. I don't
think there was any big announcement
there.
To me, if you had an easier way to get
rid of IRGC, question for you. Is the
world a better place with IRGC no longer
being in power and it being replaced by
some sort of a democracy?
Look, I completely agree with you in
that the great fear is that Iran becomes
much more extremist and much more
theoretical
theorocratic than it is now. Um the K uh
was considered a pretty moderate
individual. His son is not considered uh
moderate and also he's considered
incompetent and so the people around him
will be able to control him. We we can
expect like the most hardline elements
in Iran society will emerge triumphant
from this war if this war continues. So
my again my best advice is for these
four countries to sit down together see
Putin and Trump will agree uh to
pressure together Iran to come to a
settlement. Um listen at the end of the
day Russia is supporting Iran. If Russia
was were to support sorry if Russia were
were to pull it support it'd be very
hard for Iran to continue this war
effort that I put has a lot a lot of
leverage over Iran right and that's why
I'm saying you need these four countries
sit down together to come to an
agreement if if Trump were trying to
negotiate with Iran directly you get
nowhere but if China and Russia entered
the negotiations and they agreed on a
mutually beneficial uh global trade
relationship then then I I think you you
can get somewhere and Trump would would
I excel in such negotiations.
>> Yeah, maybe the meeting is a better
meeting if it's Russia, China, and US
and not involving Iran on phase one just
to kind of get the pulse there because
the leverage, you're right, cuz Russia's
they kind of help each other, right?
because they were selling the cheap
drones, the Shahids, I don't know what
they're called, shaved or shahed to uh
uh uh to uh Russia and Russia was buying
it from them back and forth because Iran
makes some of the best small drones
similar to uh Ukraine. Shahid. Yeah. The
drones that they make, the loud ones
that uh uh very effective in a small in
a war like this. Okay. So that that's
interesting to see what happens there.
But you do agree that the level of
extremism that IRGC has, if there is a
way to get rid of that regime and be
more of a democracy,
the world would be a safer place with
them being gone. You would agree with
that?
>> Yeah. No, I I would agree that it is in
it that it is not good. It is not in the
best interest of Iran to be to be a
theocracy. I think these are Persian
people. These are the most um you know
enlightened um people with a long
history. They want to be Persian. And so
I think that what hope what emerges
after this war is a more vibrant Persian
nationalism as a counter to Shia
theocracy.
>> So you would want to see the religious
the you know ru the hes all that to be
gone and it's just ran by government not
a theo theocratic type of a government.
You'd like to see that happen. Do do you
think there's a safe landing where we
can get there? Do you think there's a
possibility where we can get there?
>> Um, given what's happened so far, um,
and given that Trump seems intent on
attacking Iran's critical civil
infrastructure, y
>> I think this is all this is only this
will only embolden and empower
uh the most extreme religious elements
in uh, Iranian society because these are
the ones who are willing to die um, for
what they believe in.
>> Yeah, I live with them. I lived there
for almost 11 years. So I I witnessed
what they're like and the level of
radicalism that they have is is a whole
different story. Let let me ask you a
couple other questions about China with
since you're in uh Beijing right now.
There's there's this data that's going
around when China went to the one child
policy that maybe the population isn't
as big as they claim it is. I'm sure
you've seen this where the numbers are
going around, oh you know we're at 1.4 4
billion. We're at 1.3 billion. And
there's like, nah, not necessarily. You
may be at six, seven. One lady said 400
million. Mathematically, it's impossible
to be at 400 million. But some of the
numbers could say 8 900 million. What is
your guesstimation of what China's
population is today?
Um, look, I live in Beijing. I visited
China. There are a lot of people in
China. I mean, just ride the subway.
It's packed every single day. Just walk
the streets. They're packed all the
time, you know. And I travel a lot.
There are a lot of people um in China. I
can't tell you what the exact statistics
are. There's probably some overounting
because local governments tend to lie
because because obviously like the more
you people people you say you have, the
more government subsidies you can get.
So I imagine there's some population
inflation. But um I believe it's still
over a billion people. The issue in
China um is not actually population
count. The the problem in China is
twofold in that you have a rapidly aging
population. you have young people who
refuse to have kids. Um I think it's
possible in five years time. China has
the lowest fertility rate in the world.
Right now it's South Korea at 0.8.
China's about one. But I I can easily
see um China overtaking South Korea in
like 5 years time. So that's the real
issue facing China. Um China still has a
lot of people. But the um uh but the
demographic curve is going to be a huge
issue for China especially as the
population ages. Why why would they li
How does it benefit them to lie about
the population? Is there a benefit? Like
if because why would they who cares if
you're at 800 million or if you're at
1.3 billion,
right? Um the issue in China is that um
local governments tend to lie all the
time. Uh because a lot of their
promotions depend on the performance
locally, right? So it's in their best
interest to inflate just not population
statistics but also economic
performance. So I So um
>> So does so does Xi incentivize local
governments to lie? Is it is it more hey
we got to save face for the world? The
world cannot see that we're a declining
country.
What is what is the who who is
incentivizing who to lie with the data?
>> Right. So um China doesn't really care
much about the world but China is an
enclosed insular bureaucracy. So the
local governments are lying in order to
uh get more funding from the central
government, right? So obviously if you
have more children, uh you can get more
healthcare subsidies, more education
subsidies from the federal government,
especially if you're a poor province. So
that's the logic of of lying. And it's
this happens. This is a very common
practice in China where if you are in
Beijing, you just have to assume that um
all the information you're getting from
local areas are just inflated
information. Got it. Okay. But but you
don't think there's a reason there's a a
good or bad thing for the world if all
of a sudden we got the right data that
the population isn't 1.3 billion. It's
really only 8900 bill million. Would
that be an embarrassing moment for
China? Would she see that as an
embarrassing moment or no? It wouldn't
be a big deal.
>> Um you know there is concern in the
central government. Um and and the
reason why is that um China is very much
a m metric based society. It's very
utilitarian, right? So it's very focused
on economic growth. And what drives
economic growth is population growth. So
there's a real concern that as the
population declines over time, China's
economy will stagnate. But personally, I
think that this may in the long term a
good thing for China because having over
1 billion people is not necessarily a
good thing. what it what it has led to
ultimately is massive exploitation over
the people because when you have like
too many people it's like free energy
right so all you have to do is basically
um exploit them and that's what runs
your economy but because you're
exploiting people that hampers
innovation um that hampers political
development so I think if China were to
face a population crisis this in the
long term would be good for China
society and civilization in the long
term
>> yeah you kind of talk about the tank
ping movement, right? The the line flat,
I think they call it, where uh young
kids are kind of like, screw it. There's
no reason for me to give my best, so I'm
going to be a minimalist. I'm going to
do this. I'm going to do that. How are
they countering that where kids are
seeing there's no reason for me to do
996, right? Work 9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m.
6 days a week. I don't want to do it.
Who cares about this? How are they
fighting against that?
So in the 1980s uh China was embarking
on economic reform and there was a real
concern among party elders like people
who who um um went through the
revolution that brought the communist
party into power in 1949. There's a real
concern that capitalism would degrade
and pollute civilization, Chinese
civilization. They call it spiritual
pollution in 1980s. And this was a huge
concern in 1980s. And it turns out this
was correct because uh free market
reform without political reform has led
to a very utilitarian society where it's
basically get rich or die trying. And so
what what what what has what this has
led to is massive corruption, massive
inequality and massive debt in China.
And this has led to tremendous apathy
among young people because there's
absolutely no chance for a young person
to get ahead. If you started a business,
if if you got if you bought a million
dollars and you started a business, I
guarantee you no matter what business
you started, you lose all of your money
because um it's a rigged game and that's
why people are opting out. And because
of spiritual pollution, because there's
really no ideology um there's really no
um sense of nationalism in China.
There's really no motiv motivating
factor for people in China, right?
Before it was it was just like make
money but and that that was the point of
your existence. Uh before during the
course revolution it was about serving
the people contributing to the
motherland building a socialist
paradise. We you and I can disagree
about uh that but but regardless during
the cult revolution people were
motivated to make the self-sac necessary
in order to build a better China. And
now people are extremely utarian.
They're indifferent. They're apathetic.
And that's why they're like, "You know
what? Screw this. I'm just I'm just
going to sit home all day."
>> Yeah. And and and who pays them though?
Who pays them? Like, is there
entitlement programs? Are they able to
stay home all day? What is the system
for me to stay home all day?
>> A very common practice is for young
people to go work as nurses or maids for
their retired parents. Their parents
collect a very nice pension. Chinese are
very frugal. You know during COVID when
everyone was locked in their apartments
for four years, they ate they ate rice
and vegetables all those four years. So
Chinese have a lot of money saved up.
They they have saved up about 40% of
their income which is the highest in the
world. Yep.
>> So I mean Chinese can can just get by on
like white rice for the next 40 years.
>> Yeah. And and and the the idea is they
don't they don't invest much in the
stock market. They don't believe in the
market but they do believe in the real
estate side. even though the real estate
has taken a bit of a hit, but you've
always learned the discipline, the
frugality part of uh folks from China.
Let me ask another question in regards
to, you know, the the live flat. My I'm
going more on the business side with
JackM. You know, in America, everybody
knows Jack. They think about Jack. They
think about his sit down with Elon Musk,
the good exchange that they had where
Elon kind of like, "You're out of your
mind. AI is going to take over." Jack's
like, "No, it's not." And then Jack made
some comments. I'm sure you remember
when he gave a not not that strong of a
critical comment, but you know the the
probably the CCP didn't like it and then
all of a sudden Jackma disappeared.
Here's a guy at the time I don't know
what he was worth $50 billion give or
take. He's a very wealthy man. He
disappeared. What is your impression of
what happened to him? Because no one's
talking about Jackman anymore.
>> Right. So when President C came into
power um there's a real concern among
Chinese economists that the economy was
overheated meaning to put it very
bluntly there's too much corruption in
the system there was too much fraud
there was so much speculation and so it
was really about how to make a more
productive economy so there were too
many Chinese people uh who was were
engaging real estate speculation and
that's what was causing the real estate
bubble and you can't really have that as
an economy, you want people to actually
work hard, start a business, and save
their their money and make proper
investments. But everyone was just p
pouring the money into real estate
scams.
>> Um, these entrepreneurs, these
billionaires were basically creating
creating financial Ponzi schemes. And so
there's a there's a commitment among
Chinese regulators to crack down. And
this is what led to the crackdown on
Jack Ma because Jack Ma pushed back
against um central authority. And you
can't do that in China. You can't
question the authority of the
government. And Jack Ma, you know, he is
he was the richest man in China. Uh he
was the most popular man in China at
that time. And he thought that he could
change the system and he found out that
that uh unfortunately you cannot.
>> Got it. And what is the difference
between him and uh the other fellow
Jimmy? I'm trying to get his name right,
his last name right. Is it Jimmy Lei?
Jimmy Lei. Do you remember the Jimmy Le
story?
>> Right. So these are two different
societies. These are two different
political systems. Um Hong Kong is
considered um like a quasi sovereign
part of China.
>> Is that kind of like the equivalent of
like a Puerto Rico in America?
>> Exactly. Exactly. And um I mean Jimmy
Lei is an outspoken um critic of the
Communist Party. Uh he he is very
pro-democracy,
but he probably pushed too many buttons.
He probably probably crossed too many
red lines. So I think what um led to his
arrest was the fact that you had
protests in Hong Kong um about a few
years ago that called for democracy.
And this was a red line for the
communist party in Beijing. And so they
ordered a crackdown and vocal opponents
of the government were arrested or
forced into exile. Jimmy lie had the
option of um seeking exile but he
believes in um democracy and so he chose
to be a martyr and that's and and so now
he's in prison.
>> Who who is he who is he in China to
America? Like is there a comparison you
can cuz this is a guy that was a
billionaire in 2020. He was pushing
democracy. Then I think China passed a
law that you know there are certain
things you couldn't do in June of 2020,
June of 2021. I could get some of the
dates off. I think it's June 30 of 2020
that once the new national security law
was passed 11 days later he got
convicted and then he went away for 20
years. And this is a guy that owned
Apple Daily newspaper brand that played
a big role in the 2014 umbrella
movement, the 2019 Hong Kong protest. So
pretty heavy guy. But to the average
person in America that doesn't know who
Jimmy Le is, how would you say Jimmy Le
is to China what XYZ is to America?
Well, I mean America has freedom of
speech. America respects its business
people. America respects its
entrepreneurs. So it's very hard for me
to find a analogy who is American. But
you do have Russian people uh you know
these billionaires who ran foul of the
Putin regime and so they were put in
prison and then they died in prison. Um
so that's what happens in uh the
societies Russia and China when you try
to defy the government that there is a
red line in our society and that is you
cannot challenge the ultimate authority
of the government. How much interest do
you think there is in China of wanting
to be a democracy in because you know
you guys got you're one party right one
political party you don't have a lot of
choice this is what we're doing it's
just hey who do you want changing this
it's not like you have a lot of say how
much interest do you think there
actually is in saying you know what why
not why why don't why don't we go try to
have a democracy in China
>> so I've been in China for 25 years and I
can tell you that um there is almost no
interest in democracy in China because
uh for democracy to uh exist in China,
for democracy to happen in China, you
would need to have people who respected
um human rights, individual liberty, who
uh had empathy, who believed in rule of
law. And the reality is that in China,
the system isn't set up so that so that
um you the the ultimate objective is to
become a bureaucrat. That's what all
Chinese people aspire to.
>> Oh, aspirationally, meaning coming up,
you want to you want to be a bureaucrat
one day.
>> Exactly. Um and the higher you climb the
bureaucracy, the the better because
traditionally China has an empire and
the way you survive survive an empire is
to become a civil servant. And that's
why Chinese work so hard in school
because they want to pass that civil
service examination to become a
bureaucrat so then they can uh provide
guarantees and protection to their
family.
>> How long did you live in Canada and the
US?
>> So um I was born in China.
>> Okay.
>> And then when I was six we immigrated to
Toronto, Canada where I grew up. I went
to um high school there. Um I did five
years of high school because you know in
Canada we're we're slower than
Americans. uh you guys can finish high
school in four years. We need about five
years and then after that I went to Yale
for college. I spent four years there
and then I came to China and I've been
in China ever since. Uh ever since 1999.
>> So how many years did you live in US?
>> Well, four years.
>> Okay. So if you were to say the dream
for a kid in Canada when he grows up he
wants to be a the dream for an American
when he grows up he wants to be a and
you already said it what China is,
right? When you grow up you want to be a
bureaucrat. Yeah.
>> What what is your impression of what
China is, Canada is, US is?
>> Well, in Canada, everyone wants to be a
hockey player. When I grew up, I didn't
play hockey, but I wanted to be a hockey
player. I wanted to play for the NHL.
>> Yep.
>> I mean, like, and I I could I can't even
skate, okay? But I wanted to be be a
hockey player.
>> In in America, I think you want to be an
entrepreneur. You you want to start your
own business, uh, such as yourself, and
you want to make it and be independent.
You want to be free of government
control.
>> Um, and you want to be able to speak
your mind. Uh, and in China, uh, as I
mentioned, you want you want to be a
bureaucrat.
>> What What do you like about each
country? Because you chose to go back to
China. And if I'm not mistaken, what
what happened with the PBS documentary
that you tried to do that they kicked
you out and then eventually they let you
come back in in 03. I don't know what
the timeline is there, you know, because
you have a choice to be in Canada, US or
China, but you chose China. So maybe
walk through what happened when they
kicked you out and then why you chose to
go back to China.
So I came to China uh to teach English
and eventually I became interested in
journalism and I was hired to do
freelance journalism. I got a contract
from PBS to do a documentary on China's
WTO and WTO entry and this required
filming um a worker protest and there
were quite a few worker protests during
this time because there was a
restructuring of stateown enterprises
and while I was filming a worker protest
I was arrested by uh planes closed
policemen. I was put into a car and then
I was put I was sent to a hotel for 48
hours where they interrogated me. Um and
um I didn't get much sleep. I I
ultimately sent a confession that I was
working in China illegally as a
journalist. So to work in China as a
journalist, you need a journalist visa
and I was not I didn't have a journalist
visa. And so they deported me but they
didn't charge me. So I could at any time
return to China. And so eventually I
chose to return to China because um at
that time I had Chinese language skills.
I had some journalist journalism
experience and so there are more
opportunities for me in China than there
were in the United States and in Canada.
So the question is what do I see the
particular strengths of each country of
each country are? Well Canada
um you know it's it's a very stable
society. people over there are very
nice, perhaps too nice. It's almost like
they're on Valium um every single day.
Um you've been to Canada, so
>> I have many times.
>> Yeah. Right. You know, Americans are the
most creative people in the world. Very
open, very generous. If you have if you
are if you want to work hard and you
have talent, you will make it in
America. And that's not true for
anywhere else in the world. It does, you
know, it doesn't matter how much talent
you have in China. No one cares. it all
all that matters is how powerful your
family is. And that's true for most of
the world. It's not just unique to
China. I would say for most of the
world, what matters is family
connections, family background as
opposed to hard work and talent. So I I
deeply admire Americans. Um and I have
tremendous respect for American society
and culture. Um China at that time was
um an open canvas. It seemed promising.
It's it it it at that time could go in
many different directions. And so I was
young and I was really curious and I
felt that I could learn a lot more in
China and experience much more
interesting opportunities in China than
I could anywhere else really.
>> And so because you you're very curious,
you're very talented. Uh you know, you
ask you're very good communicator. I
mean these are all great qualities to be
here in the States. Why why choose to
use those talents in China?
So my so I was in the United States for
college and when I was at Yale I found
that um there wasn't as much openness
and freedom to curiosity as I imagined.
So Americans are extremely
entrepreneurial. They're very good at
business. But I didn't feel as though
um America was going to change a lot in
10 20 years time. And I felt that I
wanted to experience a society in flux
in change. I thought America was much
too stable. Um you know I could have
easily gone to law school and become a
very uh wealthy lawyer or maybe even go
gone and become a professor. Right?
There are lots of these career paths
open to me because I had a Y education.
But I knew exactly what h what what I
would be like in 50 years time or 60
years time because you know I used to
look at my professors and I I know how
they live their lives. I have friends
who are lawyers and I know how they live
their lives and I wanted to experience a
world in which um the world was
unpredictable and that was China. You
know I I I like when I came to China I I
knew China was going to change a lot in
20 30 years time and so during this time
of massive change this would offer me
opportunities to do things I could
really do in United States.
Got it. So that was the opportunity to
go over there and uh uh and by the way
your content that you create in China
that you upload on YouTube, do you also
upload it on the channels in China or is
it mainly for the content in US?
>> So I have a very strict policy of not
engaging in Chinese social media. I do
not have a Chinese social media account.
Um Chinese reporters have reached out to
have interviews with me and I've said
no. Chinese people have reached out to
me and said they want to work with me
and I've said no. And the reason why is
that um I understand
>> when you say they reached out who
reached out to you like the bigger
platforms or media companies or all the
way from the top the CCP
>> well professors professors at the very
elite universities in China Tino
University
>> um and I don't want to talk to these
people because they represent the
government
>> and I don't want want to put myself in a
position where I'm compromised and have
to become a propaganda a mouthpiece for
the government. And so, um, my main
priority is to maintain my independence,
my freedom, because I operate in a gray
zone in China where I'm not a Chinese
citizen. So, I'm not bound by, uh,
Chinese surveillance laws. Um, and I
make content for Westerners and so I
have a lot more freedom uh to comment
about Western society than say if I were
in Western society, right? So, so Canada
has become a very authoritarian society.
um they I if I said the certain things
that I said uh in Canada, then it's
possible that I get visited by the
police. Um and that that would be true
for Europe. Uh it would be true for the
United States, but there would be some
other issues as well.
>> Yeah, that's interesting. So, have they
ever knocked on your door and said,
"Hey, you cross on Elijah. Pump the
brakes. That's too much. Relax." Or no,
they leave you alone. Nobody's knocked
on your door.
>> I work at a school. I'm I'm employed by
the school. they have legal
responsibility for me and there was one
time when I wrote a substack essay that
mentioned China and I was given a call
by the school leadership and told to
pull it down. Um I'm not at liberty to
tell you what the continent was but but
I will tell you that I'm being monitored
very heavily.
>> I I can I can only imagine that. I can
only imagine that. Do you feel safe for
yourself in China long term?
>> I do not plan on staying in China long
term. Okay. Uh I figure because
>> and I I'll tell you why. Because right
now China is very interested in soft
power and right now I have a lot of soft
power. I have a lot of influence
overseas and so they want to co-opt me.
They want to compromise me and turn me
into a weapon that they can use uh to
promote their agenda overseas. And I I
don't want to do that.
>> The longer you stay, the more people are
going to think that you are somebody
that's representing the CCP, that you're
working with the government. Just so
because I know you the criticism the
moment you went viral I'm like okay
let's see what happens the next two
weeks because they're going to come for
his throat. It happens every single time
and and then we all move on with the
filtering process. You're not really a
professor. Are you a spy? Are you tied
to the government? Are you tied to this?
If all of a sudden you leave and you go
to Singapore or Dubai or a different
place or maybe maybe not even Dubai, but
a couple, you know, a couple places that
you can go to uh to speak, then that
means you truly are a citizen of the
world that your concern is here's what I
think about, here's what I want to talk
about. Do whatever you want with this
information. And I'm sure your AdSense
is picking up anyways with YouTube,
which allows you to drop your job as a
teacher to go live anywhere. That's the
beautiful thing about YouTube. So, you
kind of have a little bit of freedom to
be able to do that. And I love to see
you continue doing this because, you
know, you're you're again, you say some
crazy things, but that's good. We need
to kind of think about some of the crazy
things that can possibly happen and then
let's hash it out. Let's debate it out
and let's see what what comes out of it.
Another question for you. Um, I love
what you said. In Canada, everybody
wants to be a hockey player. In US,
people want to be an entrepreneur. In in
China, they want to be a bureaucrat.
What do you think? What do you think
kids want to be in Iran? What what what
do you what's the dream in Iran today
under this regime? I know you're not
there. I'm not there, but what do you
think?
>> Well, I I mean, I've never been to Iran.
Uh it depends where you are in Iran,
right? So, the cities are very different
from the rural areas. Um but I think
that given u what's been happening in
this war, I think there are a lot of
young children who fantasize about about
fantasize um and they grow up and they
want to fight the Americans. So, so I
feel as though this war um given the
fact on the first day the Americans
struck a a um school in southern Iran
that killed 168 school girls and they
killed an 86 year old 86 year old man
with prostate cancer. Um I I I I feel as
though there are a lot of young people
who want to go to war with with America
right now.
>> Yeah. And I agree. I agree with where
where you know the I'm gonna be a hero
one day and you'll see even in some
videos with mothers celebrating that
their sons gave their lives. It's like
my son's a hero. He did the right thing.
It's a very different way of thinking
about uh uh what what what happens there
you know very different way of thinking
about let's talk about co um you know co
is the time when I started talking about
politics up until co I had no desire to
talk politics. All I did was business
and I would do my whiteboards. You know
how you do your whiteboards? I would do
my whiteboards except uh nowadays we can
do with the nice little markers where
our hands don't get dirty. I did it the
ghetto ways back in the days where I
would get paint all over my suit and
ties and it was a hot mess. But uh
during co you know story comes out. It
came out from the Wuhan lab. No, it came
from the wet market. No, China had
nothing to do with it. Yes, China had to
do it. Nancy Pelosi goes to Chinatown.
Stop being so racist. Trump's like, what
are you talking about? It came from
China.
What does China say about COVID with
their position? Because when the state
media is telling their stories and I'm
living in Iran and they're saying, "Let
me tell you, US is the devil and US is
this and death upon America and all this
other stuff." And you know, China is a
pretty controlled environment kind of
like what you talked about earlier.
How does China state media control the
narrative of what really happened with
CO?
>> Okay. So unfortunately CO has been has
been memory hold in China. So no one
talks about it. Um it was a traumatic uh
three or four years for Chinese society
and people have just have basically just
forgotten about the experience. No one
even mentions CO anymore. People still
get CO um but no one mentions CO
anymore. So all this has been memory
hold and people would rather just move
on with their lives because there's
absolutely no point in talking about it.
But the Chinese government have said on
multiple occasions that CO started off
as a American bioweapon. And so that's
what the America what the Chinese
believe that they that CO was American
boweapon. It was leaked into China in
order to uh hurt Chinese society. And
there are a lot of elite and there are a
lot of elite Chinese who who I talked to
who believe the same thing.
>> So they believe it was a boweapon
released from US in China. That's the
narrative they say. And is it that's
what they believe that's
>> and is it tied to Fouchy the gain gain
of function is that kind of how they
spin it or what's what's their method of
t you know connecting the dots
so I'll tell you what I believe happened
okay and um so I believe that this was
American bioweapon funded by Tony Fouchi
uh Obama had put a moratorum a ban on
gof function research and so um fought I
um subcontracted gain of function
research to the Wuhan lab which was
actually a military installation
and um I don't know if it was accidental
or deliberate but it got it got released
into Wuhan and when it did get released
into Wuhan the early reporting was that
this was killing a lot of people. It was
actually burning your lungs. It was like
a furnace. Your lungs became a furnace.
So it's pretty deadly. and um they
locked down the city too late and about
a third of people like you know escaped
into other cities as well as bordered
flights for Europe and this spread
around the world very quickly. Um so I
think that's what happened. Uh but
Chinese what what they believe is that
this was an American boweapon designed
to hurt the Chinese economy and and
that's a story. Um but they downplay
China's role in it.
Yeah, they downplay China's role in it.
And culturally, is is China a culture
where if the government says says that,
don't question it. You don't have to
right to question it. Just buy it. This
is what happened. Don't come back and
question us because of freedom of
speech.
>> Chinese people know where the political
red lines are. Um, and they know how the
political winds are shifting. Um, and so
there's really no questioning of the
government.
What what an advantage for the enemy to
be able to see in America where in
America we bash each other and we're
going at it and every you know
everything's being exposed from
congressmen on the left and the right
and nobody in ch in the world can see
what's going on with China because no
one can bring up anything. God forbid if
you do something could happen.
>> I I disagree. I I think like if you want
if you want a healthy, creative,
resilient society, you need free and
open debate.
>> The the best thing about America is the
first amendment. The best thing is that
anyone can criticize the president. And
there's rigorous debate right now over
this Iran war. And this allows for
America to pivot and to be resilient uh
and to discover its weaknesses and to
improve on its witness on on on it on on
its vulnerabilities. China has been
China for the past 5,000 years. This is
not a good thing.
>> Yeah. No, I'm with you. It is. If if a
person that thinks they can have that
kind of a chokeold on their people for a
long time and see the enemy as debating
each other, a lot of information comes
in. But if so, social media apps are not
available in China, right? There is no
Facebook, there is no YouTube, there is
no X, there is no nothing like that is
available in China.
There are Chinese equivalents but yes
these u western social media platforms
are banned in China.
>> Are there any are there any like if I if
you and I go to a dinner and you know if
you live in California at the peak of uh
COVID you have to be very careful if you
were a Trump supporter a lot of people
would say but there were parties you
would go to to houses like hey man me
too hey me too but God if you wore MAGA
hat in 2017 in California go walk
through the mall and see what happens to
you. It was a very different climate
than today, right? Are there small
pockets of people in China, small
communities that are growing that
they're criticizing the government or
none of that exists?
>> None of that exists in China.
>> Okay. All right. And I don't think you
agree with that. I think
>> Well, well, well, no. I mean, the reason
is that China has developed an AI
surveillance state that is the most
advanced in the world, right? So, China
has digital ID and digital currency,
right? And so with that, everything you
do online can be monitored, right? And
so when when you use your mobile phone,
it's a it's a like all your app is on
your phone. So the government knows
exactly where you go.
>> Yeah.
>> What you buy, who you hang out with, and
from that from this from this data,
>> they they can do a micro analysis of of
your political leanings and then
influence you in a certain way. So, chi
China has developed the first AI
surveillance state.
>> Interesting. Interesting. Yeah. You
know, you just reminded me of a story uh
when I when I I made a handful of videos
criticizing China and I brought a
General Spalding who went very hardcore
at China, got millions of views all over
the place and he was revealing some
things about China. So, about it was
about a six months of going to after
China, pretty hardcore. One day I get an
email from a PR firm saying somebody
from China wants to invite you to an
event. It's it's a charity event.
>> I said, "Okay,
>> so let's do the Zoom." So, I got on the
call.
>> It's me, Mario, another guy named
Gerard, and we get on the Zoom and we
said, "So, what's the outcome? They want
to pay you $600,000." I have this email
till today documented.
>> They want to pay you $600,000,
but they want you to give a $300,000
check to XYZ charity. So, you get to
keep $300,000,
but you give the $300,000 to the
charity. We'll take care of your hotel,
food, flight, everything. don't worry
about it and we'll give you $300,000.
Of course, my answer was no. But why
would China do something like that? Why
would the why would they want somebody
like me to come in to get $600,000 and
donate $300,000 to charity?
Right? So, the Chinese approach to solve
power is co-opting
elites, right? So, in China, the elites
have all the power, the people have no
power, and they assume that's just how
the power work. That that's just how the
world works. So, um, if I'm going to
spend money on soft power, that
basically means I bribe influential
media elite such as yourself, such as
Tom Friedman. Um, so Tom Freeman has
visited China quite a lot and he said
very nice things about China and quite
honestly, this works, right? Because if
you come over in to China, they treat
you very well. It's great food. The
people are very friendly. U, they show
you the best aspects of China and you
you you leave with a very good feeling
in your heart. So Chinese are very good
at co-opting individuals and they only
focus on on individuals who have
tremendous influence in in in the world
such as yourself.
>> It's a brilliant strategy if you're able
to succeed with it and people can come
back and being complimentary about it.
You know that's that's what you want
especially in enemy state. Last question
here with Muslims and and how what what
what what is the position that Xi
Jinping or the Chinese government has
towards Muslims, the religion of Islam?
Of course, on the outside, they have a
lot of relationships with a lot of
people. But on the inside, we read read
about the Ugers. We read about the
treatment of what's happened in Muslims.
We read about how some stories of what
they think that religion is all about.
What is the sect of Muslims in China and
what is the relationship with Islam and
the Chinese government?
Right. So um there were some prominent
terrorist attacks where Muslims uh
weaguers um launched knife attacks in
train stations killing dozens of
Chinese.
And um a lot of these weaguers were came
back came back from wars in the Middle
East. So these were radicalized people
and there was real fear among the
Chinese government that um there's
there's a radicalization
had penetrated um Muslim society. So
there was a massive crackdown
um across Muslim society. But this goes
into a much larger um trend in China
which is the promotion of ethnic Han
civilization. So China has about 55
minorities. The majority like 90% of
people are Han. Like I'm I'm a Han
person. Um but there are lots of
minorities in in the borderlands. And it
was a policy of the communist party uh
in 1949 to be as tolerant as possible to
these minorities meaning that they were
given their own autonomy. Uh their
language was promoted. There was heavy
state subsidies for to protect their
culture to pro protect their language to
promote um ethnic minorities in
mainstream Chinese society. And recently
there's been a push to promote Han
nationalism which means a clapping down
on the rights of ethnic minorities. And
the most obvious example is that schools
many in many places are no longer
allowed to teach a second language.
You're if you're a minority, you're only
allowed to learn um Chinese as opposed
to your lo local dialect.
>> Interesting. So does that include
English or they teach you English in
China? They are trying to reduce the
teaching of English as well, but it is
much too popular among middle-class
Chinese who want to send their kids
abroad. Uh but but the official policy
is to uh promote Chinese teaching over
English teaching.
>> And are there are there enough like you
know the Muslims are fairly if I'm
looking at the population right now it
says 20 to 25 million Muslims live in
China, right? And roughly one and a
half% to 2%. I don't know if those
numbers are right or not. That's just,
you know, chat bringing that number up
and it explains the largest group being
the Hoi Muslims, ethnically similar to
the Hanchinese, which you were kind of
talking about right now. What What can
they do and what can't they do? Because
the Muslim religion in America grows
because we have the freedom of speech.
You can go out there and be in the
streets praying. What can they not do in
China?
Um, look, the reality is that the
Communist Party prides itself on being
atheistic. So, it is trying to downplay
religion. Um, not just against the
Muslims, but also against Christians,
against people of all faiths. And, um,
they're trying to promote communist
ideology uh, above everything else. So
you can be religious as long as you
accept that communism is the ultimate
god which is which means that most
people who are religious are not going
to accept this. Right.
>> Makes sense. Okay. So is there things
that you c do you know your limits of
what you can and cannot talk about
yourself? Like what can you not talk
about?
>> Right. So in China um there are lots of
things I cannot talk about. Uh, but I'm
not on social media. I'm not on Chinese
social media. I don't talk to Chinese
reporters. So I So I'm not constrained
by this. But because I'm based in China,
I also have to watch I I also have to um
watch what I say overseas, right? So
things I can't talk about um is
the Tibet Taiwan issues,
uh the uh Shinjang issues. I cannot talk
about this. I cannot name specific
individuals in China who hold uh
leadership positions. So you will not
hear me talk about or criticize um the
leadership of China. I'm not allowed to
discuss that. I'm not allowed to discuss
the limitations of the military because
they are invincible
um and they are always right.
Um there there are lots of things I
can't talk about.
That is funny because they're always
right. I like that because that's like
uh you know,
something tells me that was a bit of a
dig is is what it was. I'm trying to see
your facial reaction to what you just
said to see if it was a dig or if it was
uh uh what you know you can't talk
about.
Did I lose you?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So like the the connection
is isn't great actually.
>> Okay. Well, we're at the end of it,
about to wrap up. Last thing, Canada,
China, US, China's buying up a lot of
farmland in US and uh Canada. Why do you
think that is?
>> Look, the reality is that if you're a
wealthy Chinese person, your dream is to
move your assets and your family to
America. And right now in America, there
there are not that many um assets that
you can buy and and create value. So
farmland is just one um one of these
assets where you can store your wealth.
And so this is why a lot of Chinese are
buying up real estate. That this is what
Chinese do. They love buying real
estate. It's not just America. It's like
everywhere.
>> So it's not it's not any other reason
but that to your impression. It's just
they're just buying it for real estate.
They're not buying it because they want
to control farmland and they want to
control produce and any of that stuff.
You're not going there.
>> That's right. Look, look, look, I'm I'm
100% confident that this is individual
Chinese behavior where they're trying to
store their wealth. Um, look, the
reality is that if you leave your wealth
in China, it there's no legal
protection. The government can take it
take it away at any time.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you want to move it overseas and
American farmland just happens to be a
pretty good investment.
>> Do you have any travel plan to come to
the States? Are we going to see you in
the states next 30, 60, 90 days?
>> Probably not.
>> Probably.
>> Given how much is progressing, given how
much Yeah. Yeah. Look, look, look, look.
I mean, I would love to visit United
States. I would love to meet you in
person. There's quite a few people who
have asked me to visit to be on a show.
Sure. But I'm pretty sure if I go to
United States, I'm going to get punched
in the face at at some point.
I I think if you I think if you're you
know giving your perspectives like
today's interview very fair I want the
world to watch this. I thought this was
a very good conversation that some may
say it could have been antagonistic but
I actually was looking forward to having
the exact conversation you and I just
had here together. I'll give you the
final thoughts before we wrap up. Is
there anything else you want to share
with the audience before we wrap up?
Yeah. So, I think these next few days
will be crucial for the world. I pray to
God uh even though I'm not religious
that we come to a peace settlement um
that Trump tackles again and uh Iran
offers a a settlement that the Americans
can agree on. I think that the
settlement that the Iranians have
offered so far which to share control of
the moves um has has been very fair and
it's quite honestly one of the most
generous offers uh that the Americans
will get from the Iranians so far. So I
pray to God that we come to a settlement
over the next few days. But it's also
possible these few days we'll see a
major escalation where the Americans are
targeting critical civilian
infrastructure in Iran which will force
Iran to go into total war and respond
forcefully against the GCC. In which
case um it's possible that we lose
access to 20% of the world's energy and
we lose 30% of the world's fertilizer.
And this means that uh the entire world
is going to be drawn into this war and
this means that every person will be
affected.
>> Well uh appreciate that perspective.
Thank you for making the time to get on.
I really enjoy talking to you and
looking forward to doing it again.
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. I'm available
anytime. It was a great conversation.
Thank you so much.
>> Anytime. God bless. Take care. Bye-bye.
Okay. Bye bye.